we've got some thunderstorms in our
forecast today and I know that's a big
change from what we've had all week with
hot sunshine and clear blue skies but
today will look a little bit different
in some areas lots of 80s out there Sean
said it is a warm start to our Friday
best chance of thunderstorms will be to
the north and west of Las Vegas but
we're not gonna rule out that we might
see some of those thunderstorms right in
the valley best chance will be in the
mountains here of Clark County up there
at Mount Charleston a mix of Sun and
clouds
chance of thunderstorms 40% lightning
and strong gusty winds same for the lake
it's about a 30% chance out there
southeast of Las Vegas while we'll have
sunshine and a few clouds to start the
day it could wind up with some really
dangerous winds out there on the water
and lightning please be safe if you're
headed at the lake always wear life
jackets 103 for the valley and that is
still in the forecast for this afternoon
that we could get some of those
thunderstorms around 2:00 and they are
dangerous with the lightning and the
strong winds tomorrow hot and sunny at
106 speaking it sounds like a radio
station doesn't it hot and sunny 106
we're looking for blowing dust
strong winds 40 to 50 miles an hour on
Sunday as that system blows through
though wow it's gonna have a big effect
in our temps look at 90 degrees on
Monday finally some relief from all this
heat this week back to triple digits as
we head into July